[Music]
in bad daughter news/bad butter dr. OTT
Oh daughter take on the bad daughter
yeah I don't that's why he's a bad
daughter yeah I get it my man right
there submitted by three biggest Eve you
know three fingers penis is my cactus
that died you know why is because the
lady who potted it did it pot pot him
right so he died I don't say what huh
because I laid him II don't be mass
Blaney right now uh uh hey [ __ ] y'all
it's three fingers D thank you yeah I'd
legit missed him when he passed away but
then somebody explains but he wasn't
potted right girls he goes watch this
just came right out that's why I
eighteen took almost half a million
dollars of her parents money or shed and
cut off all communication gay no Peters
a rich damn how does a rich half a
million dollars Bob hi Sam
why didn't I would have done the same
really yeah because I'm imagining that
because they're rich they never really
loved her and then and then she was
raised by the maid and then the or the
nanny and then she got really really
like neglected it's just I won't [ __ ]
you did you never loved me in the first
place and then she ran away with the
money
okey Michelle and David what am I didn't
come from a rich family
where'd she get the half a million
pounds well what if I told you that her
family had been saving up to send her to
school psycho Richard familiar what
school is she going to in Canada where
I'm China half a million u.s. or half a
million China it was three million yuan
cuz it cost for twenty six thousand five
hundred and fifty US dollars she's a
[ __ ] school is this she know because
it's it's it's the it's the tuition plus
living yeah listen everything and if
before years
how did she get in how to get access to
I hate her already
she moving my [ __ ] dream I hate her
and wired the money I'm just making it
up cuz she got the money because once
she arrived to Canada she opened a
Canadian bank account and transferred
all that money oh yeah they should have
just rationed it out to her no you
probably trusted her I don't give a [ __ ]
how trustworthy like it is instead of
spending it on college it looks like she
spent it on just lavish lavish life like
just going to really high-end
restaurants 5-star hotels and luxury
goods with a boyfriend instead of going
to school she's living it up you should
blow it off just kidding just she's
messing up her own future that's true I
mean her it's sad for her parents but
it'd be is kind of her money cuz it is
for her it wasn't used what it was for
what it was intended for but she just
[ __ ] ruined her a lot if she took all
the money at once that's not even
fdic-insured she should have at least
taken like another account all I know is
steak tastes better when you earned it
with his better steak tastes better when
you maybe your flavour piece wow I Jack
MIT didn't take those two fingers hang
them on a rope and then snip them off
that's it looks like an extra finger
popping out oh yeah [ __ ] China and then
beat that it was this I was like what
the [ __ ] is this but there's two fingers
down through though oh [ __ ] it looks
like this right she has an extra finger
right here deform that sphere six finger
[ __ ] yeah I share some photos of her
posting like her going out and so I'm
grateful man
you don't know what type of parent she
had we don't know you don't know finally
gets to escape yeah this whole stories
from the death perspective too so
apparently what's been happening is that
her dad has been trying to contact her
she just cut off all communication took
all the money isn't studying and so the
father was sending her messages on on
what we chat and Weibo and and then he
was just saying like like this quote I
feel I feel have nothing to be sorry for
if there's anything you can point it out
for me
your mother doesn't approve your
behavior either given that you're my
daughter I don't want to take things to
the extreme also it's not safe for you
to carry such a large amount of money
with you you should be clear who sent
you to study abroad everyone must be
grateful not to mention I am your father
I've said everything I need to say and
then there's like more messages like
I'll expose every horrible thing you did
on Weibo wait but what no matter if
you're in Canada or America you'll be
found sooner or later I hope you can get
a clearer understanding of the situation
and won't be blinded by your lust for
money and then yeah you just talking
[ __ ] to her how the [ __ ] is he gonna get
her back you stupid dick down they found
her did they find her not to my
knowledge
oh so they just the parents sent those
pictures yeah so then the dead ended up
posting this on Weibo and then that's
when he got really viral what a dumb dad
and there's like two sides to this so
it's one side there's mixed reactions
one side is siding with the father
saying that like she's just [ __ ] cold
and heartless how could she do this to
her family I mean looking at it the
wrong way and then the other side is
founding finding fault with the father
for trying to intimidate her and his own
daughter that's just that's already a
glimpse of how their relationship is it
doesn't matter about the relationship
because that's personal the point is
like financial and I'm not sure even in
the States if so you give somebody money
for a specific purpose it you can't
necessarily like you can't nah doesn't
matter if the money goes into the
account and you have access to it that's
it yes
yeah I have known people that got [ __ ]
like through business because someone
had their name and access to the account
and gambled it all away yeah Oh like
verbally like if it's like simple does
not spend more yet oh that's true unless
it was a specific account that you open
up that says this money can only be hang
it on the Weibo what if what they have
what other we like the money like what
they're suppose what doesn't mean
anything she agrees to it that doesn't
mean anything
I mean and on top of that how do you
even go after that like what what can
happen like you're gonna sue your own
daughter you're gonna take him to jail
you can't I mean like you could do that
without hey I feel like posting pictures
of her someone finds her then they know
that she has all this money [ __ ]
yeah he's kind of petty the way he's
handling it like put her in danger
yeah cuz he's saying like people will
find you specifically now I think it's
like why don't you ask yourself where
did you [ __ ] up to where your daughter
had to steal this money and run from you
what did you and in he he gets he tries
to get her back by electing her in the
[ __ ] email saying I'm gonna expose
you and actually exposing not a good
pretty boy like yeah so so going back to
imagine what's happening in a home yeah
there's no love in that house I tell you
that she's probably like living her best
life I hate that phrase but no honey you
think I don't know I see thievery as
thievery it is what it is because a
wrong doesn't fix another wrong you know
what I mean yeah so she wanted to be
independent she could have done that on
her own without stealing her she's just
as much of a [ __ ] scoundrel - I mean
yeah I mean I just I just don't excuse
trash the trash like it doesn't make
sense to users yeah because there's
there's always this argument of light
Steve is a fruit farmer I know did you
know what trees are yeah we plant them
do you know what hills were no two
Wong's don't make a price damn straight
it finally worked like that I mean we
really don't know what's happening
behind me you know closed doors but just
the fact that the moves that they both
made just shows that they're both
a both shady there's two ways this
happened she was either a [ __ ] dick
face daddy and really really mean or
they were too damn nice and too
permissive so that's what happened if
he's too damn nice too permissive I
don't think he'd have the balls to
expose her like this unless he's
desperate now cuz even though he's China
and tomater
he still sounds like a [ __ ] yeah you
know it sounds like you know your dad
did I mention I'm your dad
do you remember that's like when you're
trying to tell your dog sit sit come on
come on you want your drink come on cuz
if I was the dad if I really want to
intimidate are just playing hey you know
what you're not gonna hear from me but
just wait because your boyfriend's gonna
be dead in a few months there you go I'm
not to say [ __ ] and that's it I could we
don't say like I have your boyfriend's
information you didn't have to say all
that you're just like your boyfriend is
gonna be missing toes and fingers and
whatever or you can come home goodie
mean that you would just have to say you
know who your father is and you know
what's gonna happen
yep and there's leave it at that cut him
off and next thing you know she wakes up
in her bed with all her boyfriends
fingers chopped off next to her while
he's hung up like this bleeding on his
own face the front of Sam wood or some
[ __ ] but that's half a [ __ ] million
dollars and my own flesh and blood does
that to me I will turn into that man
[Laughter]
in the bot in the violin sense I just
made you this this child I dumped all my
love it this is this is assuming that my
really good father yeah yeah yeah I
didn't do what we might was putting
yourself you're a whole sovereign issue
yeah like if I was a good father to this
kid and you just turned out to be this
piece of [ __ ] which I will have to take
some responsibility for yeah you still
half a million dollars that I earned
busting my ass to give you an education
and you [ __ ] take that away and give
it to your boyfriend I have to kill your
boyfriend I'll just cry yet the kill the
boyfriend for not even setting her
straight and accepting it like a bit cuz
I don't want to kill her because I want
her to live through her mistake so i'ma
kill everybody she loves around her damn
but then she might try to kill you you
could try I will kill you before you
didn't think about killing me I will
slice your [ __ ] nose off it's like a
family of ninjas I hope Tyco is a nice
guy oh yeah pretty nice he's pretty
happy you like such a happy soul doesn't
know jack [ __ ] either
he's very happy I see like you know
babies they're not as happy as taiga
happy hell I mean I should have called
the matter
I like how I curl watches TV cuz he
reminds me of an old man just on the
lazy boy chair it is so cute like yet a
rough day man I had my mouth open all
day yeah I hope you don't have to be up
his boyfriend I know I don't want to she
was gonna beat up the boyfriend all
right yeah that sucks though man I know
and then the dad's also saying that he
will contact the consulate general the
People's Republic of China
the consulate general know gently over
there kidnapper ass [ __ ] and he's like
in some in every resource that might
disposal to find you I have an ending
sounds like he found it like the reverse
Liam Neeson so protecting there's no
finder yeah
a kick you thought his ass boyfriend's
parents information and
but thank he's like I didn't tell them
what happened because I haven't lost
hope of you coming back oh come on you
don't have [ __ ] but I feel like don't
you get taxed on that at least in the
u.s. like you can only give up to like
$26,000 or something like it's pretty
small to your kid otherwise they get
taxed as income what would you give a
young child half a million dollars
that's the dumbest thing I thought what
I've done it in a heartbeat
alright yep apparently he's jobless the
dad is jobless no he's a crook that's
what has a lot of fun the lot I don't
know this is just a very sad story and
we like to fill in the blanks yeah our
brains do if we don't have the complete
story that we fill in a hole all holes
because we our brains delusions have
been really yeah yeah my life is
illusion then
[Music]